I mean we got a 99 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes right now from audience which
is really yeah yeah we didn't even check
yeah we're like seven seven out of ten
movie must actually be good guys yeah
ninety-nine percent in fact out of seven
thousand movies where were ranked number
one on audience rated movies that are
available now to rent so it's really
cool yeah we should have started off the
interview with three tickets have a
wonderful time in the nation of Colombia
good think about it who listened twenty
five million dollar reward for the
capture this dude I'm doing this Benjen
what have you done now you don't
remember anything you lost your mind
and you wiped your job and your dignity
so do something how about bring us to a
third world country to catch on combien
cartel drug lord is a good idea
e tomu is coming on vacation I didn't
know he's gonna be doing Rambo she know
they got dirt man
You Know Who I am mr. Pomeroy cartel
members kidnapped our friend we were
told that you can help us what are you
doing oh yeah gentlemen welcome to my
training ground first lesson always be
aware of your surroundings you stayed up
all night painting yourself like your
wall forever only one thing you need to
know to keep from getting killed in
battle a little reject nation it's Greg
Alba here that's John Humphrey over here
with us today it's Blake Freeman Blake
Freeman is oh my god you gotta be
kidding me you would not be in a vintage
real rejects video if that wasn't going
on right away
silent day only to have noise begin
directly when I'm in the dogs are back
in that Lake Freeman is the writer
director producer and star of the movie
all about the money he actually just an
interview recently at schmoes know at
their fancy studio and Collider and now
he's here now apartment from that yeah
biggest this is the next step from the
next level of devotion for your movie
right you're not a short the show is
awesome I love it so thanks hell with
you Trish into market yeah we saw the
trailer for this and I'll be honest
whenever we get asked to interview
someone this fear comes over John and I
yeah which is what if the trailer is
[ __ ] what if I don't what if I actually
don't like it and I got a [ __ ] my
way through an entire interview with
someone take that magnify it by ten
million and then know where I stand
and I don't know whether or not it's
good oh I know the feeling feel like
that's the process for anybody who makes
comedy but we saw the trailer and we
ended up really liking the trailer which
is a delightful surprise there's so many
questions that did pop into my mind
going through this but I think I'm just
gonna start off with a complicated one
when we were asked to do this interview
we were told you have this crazy story I
heard it works be like interesting
troubling turbulence and I got no
details as to what they were complying I
don't know what story there's a lot of
stories so when you're making
independent movies everything that you
think and have been told will go wrong
does and then some and then you just
make up a bunch of other [ __ ] and it
actually happens - I mean it's not
glamorous like that but I think I know
what you might be talking about we're
talking about the PR rep as well there
is a scene and now I'm direct and then I
have to go and and people are like do
you ever go back and you know do you
watch the scenes you're just in like a
like a normal director and I'm like yeah
or I'll rely on my director of
photography Ryan purpose or Marvin
Wilson who is also a guy behind the
camera for me and I'm like alright did
we get it you know and they're 70 people
on set watching and you know they're all
just kind of nodding yes or no sometimes
you want to take their word for it well
there's a scene in the movie where we go
to Columbia we go to a party we get
really messed up we do a bunch of
cocaine me and Eddie Griffin we go to
separate bedrooms with these girls and
the girl that I take in as she turns
around I find out she's not a girl
completely new whole [ __ ] thing that's
a scene where it's only funny if your
face is right near a penis and I just
said that out loud
I'm terrible about myself you know we
shoot it and I jump back and then we
shoot the whole thing and then I look
over and they're like dude it's just
blurry let's do it again we're on the
17th take the executive from Warner Bros
who came out there yeah yeah they came
in a stay until 3 o'clock just to see
the scene and I look over and on like a
live man
my to nip the nose on one of them and I
I looked and I said we gotta be done
with this what's going on I look over
there and they're all crying we got it
on the first take crap that yeah dude
that's a team you can rely that is you
know I've heard troubles and turbulence
that was not story I was expecting 15
years to put together we're making the
movie and right before like three days
before we're about to start shooting
come to find out this happens all the
time a lot of filmmakers know what I'm
talking about independent for sure movie
was a million and a half we had a guy
that was putting in a million dollars
and he backed out he didn't back out if
it backed out it a bit fine he was just
a douchebag that lied oh you mean the
money is not in the bank I'm gonna bei
am and I'm in commitments for seven
hundred thousand dollars at this point
and there's really nobody to blame so
when you make a movie independently
people will go well you know if they
don't do their job there's really only
one person to blame you can't go well
the sound person sucked or at least
because it all comes back to me right
right well same thing with these
guarantees you know we had I don't
200,000 and and locations and then
400,000 of people's salaries whatever it
was you know that you had to pay up
front that are due and then you don't
have any money you're like do I just bag
it and then pay this off for you here so
you know working at Starbucks you know
did we just try it was funny a
girlfriend of mine it was sitting does
she work for us on the set we've been
friends for years well how much do we
need to get going and I'm like 250 grand
she goes oh I got that it's not the time
wait a female friend of yours yeah okay
she worked on the movie she cuts this
check for 250 grand and then the movie
just starts you know going and then
we're stopping scenes and I'm outside
raising money how we're in there and
then we raised another million and over
the next three or four days it was
insane nobody can accuse you of not
being dedicated you know it's it's funny
because the first couple of days I'm
literally like a deer in headlights I'm
just kind of dead and you know couple
times a day would be like look I need
you to come back around okay you're
thinking who do I call next who do I
call next that part is not fun we got an
amazing crew and I know everybody always
talks about that and they love it we
actually do I mean we would all blow off
steam and party you know nice really
when we needed to and we were good
friends and so you didn't have that you
know there's a weird thing that goes on
in this business where they have bread
in where it's us against them the
filmmakers are the bad guys and then the
the crew and everybody else is like
they're two separate entities constantly
bitching and fighting and I hate that
you know we're kind of like I mean not
to sound stupid but we're like that
Madonna you know before they go on we're
all holding the hands you know let's do
it we weren't really holding hands I was
just saying how shitty would it be to
work anywhere else right here right now
we're all get pumped up that way you
know we didn't have all of the money
that we needed at the right time and
everybody stepped up you didn't have to
hear about it they just did their jobs
they said we beat expectations by 1,000%
which means that rotations we're good
it's done in like insanely better than
what we thought and now we've got a call
for it to be a TV show our really really
congratulations yeah you heard it here
first
yeah this was not mentioned on shows no
no was it maybe wasn't yes so I gotta
ask though every when we suddenly see
the trailer and you see people like
Eddie Griffin in there and Casper Van
Dien I'm man to people I watched a lot
in the 90s because you're like writing
and directing and acting in this it's a
lot of multi
right was there any intimidation factor
at all oh yeah in terms of like working
with people who've been around in films
for quite a while and here you are
taking on this huge mantle of the best
question anybody's asked because nobody
ever has that the answer is nervous as
hell like the first two not on top of
all the crap that I was dealing with you
know getting the budget while we were
filming you're sitting there with people
who are and Jon Gries who was uncle Rico
Napoleon um I knew and taken and all
these other great movies he's just
fantastic gosh he's I've worked with him
already but here I'm sitting in a scene
and this first and second day is me and
him and Eddie Griffin at a table and I'm
trying to hold mine and I don't at all
on that scene and that was you'll know
that those are the first two days we
somehow cut around the shittiness of
Blake really I mean those things look
good because I was intimidating like
crazy is this the scene where you were
this the three of you and he makes that
sound you're like yeah you're in there
and it's you know we're in a huge set
it's the biggest set we've had we've
made two of the movies the first one was
$200,000 I was newbs
anyway made a journey plan of sanity
which was a documentary that was a half
million it's our first what we felt it
was a big-budget movie you know it was
anything cool looks a thousand dollars
is a lot of money yeah yeah I mean for
us is a big budget and you know but a
lot of people stepped up in in Hollywood
and gave us a lot of things like
literally a month before we start
filming I was at a party and this guy
goes I like you I'm gonna give you the
Scarface mansion to film at he was just
full of [ __ ] like everybody else and I
get a call the next day and this guy
goes so you're gonna film here and I'm
like look I gotta be honest we don't
even have the budget he goes no no we're
giving you the house yeah and I'm like
what is the world forty million dollar
estate
nobody's filming their cent Scarface and
here we are given the place
and it makes the movie just feel so much
bigger so then what we did we went back
and we changed every location cut every
time yeah get every single favor that we
had to pull just to make the rest of the
movie match and you know in a in a big
film when you put in this project
together though cuz I feel like Eddie
Griffin and Casper Van Dien or two very
specific personalities I wrote for them
you wrote for them we judge another
reward the movie person we wrote for
Casper yes he was in newbs with me
I guess a friend of mine and what people
don't know he's never been in a comedy
before what people don't know is that
guy is one of the coolest nicest
funniest people that you ever heard he's
funny and he's cool and people don't see
it or get it they only see him in these
were like serious movies oh yeah yeah
he's missed casting the guy really
really good and he killed it I thought
you did a great job and then I wrote it
for him I wrote it this neurotic guy of
the three of us and then I just wrote
myself as kind of an [ __ ] which I'm
really good at that so good hey man I
can pull this one off no losers and then
Eddie Griffin I wrote it for him and
then he called me and he goes who wrote
the black parts and I said I did and he
goes no you didn't who wrote the black
rice I said any I wrote and we were
talking about it at Eddie's house the
other night and he was like let me call
you back
it calls you back on who wrote the black
part someone good so we we got in there
and they're called John rice and I said
listen I want you to play this crazy
military ex-military guy that trains us
and it took him just a couple of seconds
to say yes I think you might note the
crazy military part we're gonna have to
kill for that he's awesome you know
I mean that guy is just he's incredible
and then danny trejo wrote it for him I
may be fun or right for Danny Trejo I'm
going to get that special with it he
adds the rest
he's just intimidating you know he has
that presence if I met him before he's
really friendly actually yeah when we
were doing that our trailer review what
we were thinking was this kind of feels
like a bro fantasy yeah you know like
guys going on vacation and they kind of
land themselves in an action movie yeah
and what so when did you come up with
this story like what how did it inspire
you or something what happened no no
like everything we make you know I mean
if you don't do something that's
commercially I I'm I'm not an artistic
director you guys are gonna get that I
got trans penis in my film I would like
to do commercially viable things things
that I think people will laugh at and
that have a chance to to be passed
around and we do them out of a budget
level that we know we can make more of
them because we hope we can get that
money back I mean it is a business and
so we took that mindset in and you find
out what the need is noobs there was no
comedies about eSports
out for the first one to do that and
then we made that then debunking and
alien psychics paranormal that's the
second most argued thing as paranormal
you know behind religion in the world
let's make a movie about it and then
show these what I feel are crack nuts
I'm the skeptic but anyway show this and
and that one did well and then you know
the other one was we were thinking about
it guys lay around on a freakin I've
done this out of it yeah lay around on a
couch and then they were looking for
what's his nuts in Iraq what a nice -
yeah
so and you know a guy owed a dream and
what we did we would daydream about man
or talk about it if I went over there
I'd find that guy this and that well
then there's a story that happened and
this is the best part it was the Crips
and bloods got together and like ten of
each really came together and said
you're gonna go oh this is so stupid and
it's true they get on a plane they get
over there in the first 24 hours they
were all shot and killed at once you see
so these other guys decided to write
this this story around it now we found
out about story I looked the story
didn't like the story but I said the
idea the premise is good so I changed it
to Colombia and then you know let's go
after somebody and then wrote it on
that's pretty neat because you found
them you found what was funny about that
yeah it's the way you told that story it
sounds funny because of how you cuz I'm
sure if I've heard that story from the
news it wouldn't tell it like this is
something silly oh yeah now I'm
imagining like a gritty and some bad
things in there you wrote it and you
directed it did you later act I imagined
got like comedians like any Griffin
there do you let them improvise and
scenes of course yeah yeah they're so
far off we forgot moviemaking Eddie and
I get kicked out of hotels in Vegas
still constantly and just start ranting
he's awesome you just gotta let him go
and then you know I mean Jon Gries and
all Casper everybody just went and they
went off that must be fun to see Casper
letting loose like that
that was one of the most surprising
things about the trailer for me is I you
know knowing knowing him from a bunch of
genre stuff like oh cool I'm excited to
see you stretch your legs in a comedy
like this you know it's cool man and
he's so good in it yeah yeah like I said
for it he just he needs to be more
comedy I was actually curious because
especially in the in the third part of
the trailer they're like the action
looks pretty intense like is this like
an action movie and sometimes it's hard
in an action comedy to make the action
look good so like how did you approach
the action like did you take inspiration
from any place yeah so Hank who does a
lot of I guess any second unit directing
for Michael Bay and them so he's a
friend called on a favor and got those
guys and dust and those guys came and
they directed all of that for us
basically I I just watch this [ __ ] ton
of those movies when I was growing up
yeah and I was shooting you know lots of
ak-47s and everything you know fire and
everywhere and that's their fantasy yeah
yeah they'd bring any like Michael Bay
trademarks with them like is every one
of that scene really sweaty and like a
lot of don't really know we're actually
filming shooting over here who's that
girl in the who's like Ashley Thomas is
her name yeah this is her first film
really yeah how'd she do she's good she
did a great job not the first time she's
ever acted but it was first time first
film no feature Lin Shaye isn't it when
I saw that I was yeah no wind shaving
favorite people in the world by the way
Lena's is awesome I'm pretty sure that
we were crying and holding each other
talking one day she's she's the best she
was the do you know who win is she was
high I can pretend Magda on something
about Mary the yes yeah when I said I
was gonna get into this business I'm
gonna put her in everything I do and I
have oh it's good to have that
collaboration she DeNiro to your
Scorsese yes
she's like the main insidious with
Tucker inspect yeah yeah yeah yeah you
should know this yeah it's good not to
talk about history we got a couple of
questions from people over our patreon
that I saw the trailer wanted to ask you
okay why does it suck so how hard is it
to how hard is it the right to a comedic
sir yes he has to learn the grammar I'm
writing as well I wanted to write a
community hard is it to write a comedic
script well there are two answers to
that are you saying that I'm not funny I
don't know how people write scripts I've
never been to any school of filmmaking
at all I just did it based on throwing
up and watching stuff and I was like
this needs to cut here this needs to cut
here I do think that's the best thing
that I do is that I know when to cut and
when to leave a joke alone and
I'm gonna bring it back up again I think
I'm good at that yeah other than that
you know in my mind as I'm writing them
you know the comedy is going on in my
mind which either one makes me
completely freaking whacko or that's
what everybody does I don't know so I'm
like playing it out and they're talking
and I wanted to take you to write this
script I'm gonna tell you this one the
first rough draft was 12 days that's
quicker than any short a month it
doesn't mean that it's that I feel that
you know it was less than it could have
been I mean it is just that comes to me
really quickly you seem passionate about
it when you're passionate about writing
something assuming it comes together a
lot quicker when you're writing it yeah
yeah I sit there and laugh at it and I'm
like oh god you got a premiere yeah how
did this movie end up changing from what
you originally planned Garrett hood for
how this thing change one we didn't have
any money three days it was funnier than
I expected because the people were able
to go off script when we got on there
when we got out into each of these
settings a lot more ideas came up and we
have that kind of thing where everybody
gets to throw in ideas so I had this
white wall and you know I was walking
through each scene and I'm like okay I
walk into this room because the first
movie we did we hired set dressers and I
says we're gonna kill him
set dresser is watching this I walked in
and I'm like I'm a gamer and when we
walked into the room everything about
the room was like pro-gaming this and
there was just crap everybody was not
anybody's room okay and I'm like I want
everything to look realistic and so what
we did is we I drew every single room
out as this movie on I'm like all right
we walk in here what do we see and I
have all 20 people pre-production going
we got an old lady smoking cigars
yes and so we literally just drew it out
and wrote in all the props and
everything in there it was so much
better I'll never do another movie
differently man it just let everybody go
you know it would be funny is if we have
a little person and then he's running
the hotel and then he's also the DJ you
know that's a bar and so we're like this
is incredible so we started doing that
is really funny man just letting a lot
of Minds come together so you seem like
you really embrace the creative
collaborative process creatively
speaking there are not a lot of good
creative people in this business let's
just be honest or this stuff would not
be bad as a collaborative unit there are
a lot of good people that can be
collaborative creatives that make you
say yeah yeah there are a lot of bad but
you get you guys cringe when you have to
watch some trailers and things like that
I mean what I love I love all trailers
it's not easy and you know but then if
you take what you think is a decent
starting base and then let everybody
throw in on it and then you can just sit
through and you can make a better
project and you know it's like one big
family
yeah when we make something it's not I
mean we started off talking about us but
it sounded like you have this is
community bonding together the whole
time yeah if it seems like you really
thrive on experience you're obviously
you know leveling up each time you make
one of these it seems like do you have
like a dream movie that if you had all
the resources you would go nuts nuts on
like you know just unlocking your inner
art director um you know the cool thing
is just recently after this movie came
out by the way it's been beyond our
dreams of successful so far hell yeah
and it has helped thank you and it has
helped a lot so Jon Gries and I are
doing a show together called planet
sanity one of my dream projects is is
something that antara sitting over here
on the under for you guys cars right
there hi time so we wrote a children's
story which is super cool
and we fly to London next week for our
publishing rights yeah and it's gonna be
an animated future and then we have one
of the partners in it was former
executive activision he's making the
game so that that is super like I'm
super stoked about and then yes there's
another one that is it's kind of a
modern-day mob based thriller then I
have not started I started to script yes
that was almost finished but that's the
movie that I want to make things have
gotten easier to make and move forward
night especially those you know the kids
book the other TV show it gets easier as
it goes it's pissing in the wind when
you stuck you smile but it's really
tough it's I mean nobody won 30 minutes
excuse my analogy which I'm obviously
terrible but I said I was like a pig
with a you know it's only so many
nipples and there's a hundreds of
piglets trying to get a nipple and
everybody's like trying to keep you out
it helps when you have the right
representation I ripped over at WME that
helps a big law firm helps Richard
Konigsberg is my manager he's awesome
it's getting easier so I think I'll be
able to make a lot more than you know
that I want to we have a show called
randoms which were almost ready to go
into production on it's a scripted show
kind of like Silicon Valley based in the
eSports world oh cool yeah yeah so we're
doing that and we got major pro teams
like team optic and hector the owner and
all these guys are gonna be doing their
cameos throughout that and that's a
really cool show good budget for us and
and yeah we're super excited about that
one do congratulations I want success I
hope you have a massive indie hit film
so that way you can sell out and do some
major studio film yeah
comic book movie not have any creative
control over it mm 5 mm 5 to slap your
name on there I passed on a couple of
other scripts that were good paydays
that's good to hear the yeah
I was broke at the time but I was like
oh you're only remembered for what you
do somebody else is mine and I have to
do it I feel like it's just there's
nothing that yeah sweet all right well
thank you for letting me chill there's
no thank you thank you for being here
great show thank you really easy to
converse with you yeah really is it
conversatio guys Blake Freeman make sure
we I'll put the link in the trailer
isn't this on demand right now it's on
arrow yeah yeah we should probably talk
about the [ __ ] movie so find you
first
you know iTunes and Amazon and you
probably still it if you look hard
enough and turn it don't don't give you
tips on how to do yeah so it's out right
now and and check it out and if you
truly hate it after you watch it then
just find me on social media I think
it's good I think it's funny I mean we
got a 99 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
right now from audience which is really
yeah we didn't even check yeah we must
actually be good guys yeah 99 percent in
fact out of seven thousand movies where
were ranked number one on audience rated
movies that are available now to rent so
it's really cool yeah we should have
started off the interview with I think
you got a baby driver that true
blake freeman all about the money is the
movie where Greg and John with the real
reject subscribe take care peace